why do I want to roll these these two
chapters together and kind of fuse them
into one is it just because they're sure
no the first one short the second one
what isn't it's because a lot of these
themes and events are overlapping with
each other quite a bit the American
Revolution was in part a political
revolution but it's also liked your book
points out to some degree also a
religious revolution some of the things
that we're going out in the history and
the story up until this point are
preparing their way for the revolution
it was a revolution in part against the
British king but also against the
British church and this notion of sort
of top-down governance you see that the
groups in the United States who
particularly stressed local authority
like the Puritans the Congregationalists
right individual churches covenant with
each other the Presbyterians they were
the ones who are really the backbone of
the revolution you see some other groups
predictably enough like the Quakers or
the Anabaptists will be often call the
peace churches try to remain neutral why
would they do that that's an expression
of their their religion other groups you
know unfortunately for them the
Anglicans many of them actually cited
against the revolution with the British
crown and suffered because of it some of
them had to go to Canada when their
goods were confiscated some of them
fought as as Tory's in militia against
the Revolutionary Army and the
the militias and that handy you know
find themselves kind of scares so this
was not just a political event but it
was something that actually divided in
part along religious lines I'm like your
book points out the first Great
Awakening is in a certain respect the
first truly American events in a sense
of something that unites all the
colonies and produces a consciousness of
Americans vs. British us versus them
over there and we're telling us what to
do so you can read the whole history
that you guys remember from you know
your early American history classes in
high school or you know things you've
taken hear about the Stamp Act and the
Tea Party and all those sorts of things
you can read that into this this
religious framework as well now I don't
talk that much about the the beginnings
of the revolution I want to talk about
the the effect of it unlike many
revelations it's actually successful so
what's the next thing you have to do
after you've had a successful revolution
besides party yeah have a good time
because you keep the bad guys out what
do you need to do
listen yeah so you have to find some way
to let's say consolidates consolidate
the the games right consolidate
achievements and what was this one about
one of the British king and the
Parliament out of their business they
wanted to be self-governing and so they
were now that brings about a whole set
of other problems right to be
self-governing once you no longer you
guys are familiar with this from going
to college right when you were living at
home under mom and dad's rules perhaps
you rebelled against them and you broke
your curfew or stuff like that but
you're still you don't get some sort of
structure or check once you're totally
rebellious kid but once you get to
college what happens your first semester
here what sort of temptations do your
face there's that that can happen in
high school I'll do right what else more
specifically about about the kind of
lifestyle you living I think it's
drinking it supposed to be part of that
lifestyle but what else there anyone
who's going to make you something wrong
that's it so you're on your own side law
enforcement going on yeah if you don't
show up to class what's the teacher
going to do are they going to call your
mom and dad and like they would in high
school and say ah Jimmy hasn't been in
class for several periods you know maybe
you should have a talk with him that's
not going to happen you decided when
you're going to wake up you decide what
you want to do if you're going to buy
yourself drink of low things off you
decide what your social life is going to
look like that's you know that's
self-governance now management's not
just one person going off to college but
a whole country full of people who don't
all see eye to eye about things and I
are faced with the same basic problems
that everybody else is throughout
history you have to keep order you have
to build roads and bridges
you have to regulate commerce you have
to make sure that criminals actually get
taken off the streets and locked up or
whipped or you know hung or whatever
you're going to do with them a lot of
women hanging back then compared that's
locking up compared to now you know you
have to do a lot of things in terms of
governance and at the start there is
their states right and they have these
articles of confederation that don't
actually work very well there's
discussions about the United States
actually breaking up into four different
countries I don't know have you ever
read The Federalist Papers or the anti
federalist papers but those were live
proposals at the time to have four
different countries because they thought
of themselves is very different from
each other and some of the differences
he had to do with let's say religious
difference you know the southern states
the Anglican Church had dominated and
you had a few areas where you know
Presbyterian to dominate or Baptist were
moving down there New England was
dominated by the Puritans wasn't it
remember for a while if you weren't
appear that you had to get get out of
there you go over to Rhode Island or
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania was a whole
different ballgame anybody was welcomed
in Pennsylvania more or less New York
was its own kind of weird animal as well
New Jersey was heavily dominated by by
Presbyterians all these different states
you know some of them may have a state
religion some of them may be completely
against that sort of thing so they had
to figure out some way to make this
actually work you know then there's the
danger if they don't make it work the
British are going to come back in or the
French will come come down from the
north and eventually take over this is a
danger that stayed around by the way all
the way through the Civil War you know
the British and the French were sitting
on the sidelines during the Civil War
just waiting for the nation
to fall apart the Russians actually sent
sent ships move either not to sort of
ward off the French and Germans the
French and the English from that so your
book lays this out as a real set of
issues that have to be worked out and
one of the things that we want to think
about with this is what your book calls
is a one word this is the ambush that's
part of the American experience there
were state churches as a matter of fact
in most countries in Europe there was a
state church at this time the Anglican
Church could be Lutheran Church could be
the Reformed Church but it was going to
be some church somebody was in charge
somebody was probably actually getting
paid from the state taxes to support
their particular view of Christianity
that was still going on in Massachusetts
in Connecticut so certain extent
Virginia with the Anglican at the time
of the revolution so the question was
should should they move towards know
though what does this mean this means no
state supported or official church
nobody gets an advantage over everybody
else like your book says Pennsylvania
Rhode Island kind of led the way what
island didn't have a state church rhode
island was where you could go if you
didn't fit into the established churches
and the other colonies pennsylvania
deliberately set up to be diverse in
that respect Marilyn to a certain extent
until they you know voted it out the
other middle colonies New York
Delaware New Jersey had most limited
establishment the opted for pluralism
they opted for saying we won't have any
state church when the issue came up
Virginia your book talks about it was a
hotly debated issue should there be a
state church or not and Jefferson and
Madison played an important role in
making sure that that didn't help how
does this pan out constitutionally is
his religion mentioned in the
Constitution yeah yeah where is it
there's really only two spots first yeah
everybody forgets about the other one so
don't feel bad because it's kind of
buried now the First Amendment is an
amendment to the Constitution part of
the Bill of Rights and so it's not in
the original work right the article 6
that's part of the original Constitution
I shouldn't say originals I mean with
the amendments they voted on that that's
that was the working document right but
article 6 was part of the original
document and an article 6 forbids
religious tests it says you can't
require somebody to belong to a
particular religious group or not or to
not belong to religious group in order
to hold office so office you know
anything from dog catcher all the way up
to president should in theory be open to
everybody no matter what their religious
views are doesn't mean that they'll get
voted in right somebody has some sort of
religion that says we need to sacrifice
every tenth person to boobity boobity
make up something some God's name
they're not going to get voted in
hopefully right there's nothing but
there's there's no exclusion of them
they can put their name on the ballot
they can make up their own party you
know the human sacrifice party and then
it's left to the voters to decide
First Amendment's been much more
important what is the First Amendment
for those of you that remember that
story to the Constitution what is going
to say about religion we really two main
things they would remember yeah freedom
to practice its official state believe
very good so one part is freedom what we
call religious liberty or freedom you're
supposed to be allowed to practice your
religion without being discriminated
against without being excluded that
suffering penalties because of that
again you know if your religion required
human sacrifice one foot once a month
that would be hard to work yet because
that interferes with other people's
rights like the right not to die pretty
important right but there you know so
long as you're not actually breaking
some sort of not just even necessarily
written lot of some sort of horrible you
ought to be able to practice your
religion that's what it says create a
religion and then no establishment
Congress shall not establish any
religion yeah there's been lots of
debate back and forth about exactly what
that means here to be just one example
that we could use out of the literally
hundreds that we might look at it in
history for a while it was common
practice that the King James Bible was a
textbook in grammar school they would
they would read portions of it and maybe
even talk about it and comment on it now
why would that be a problem King James
Bible that doesn't really belong just a
wannabe religious group right there's a
lot of Protestants against Bible who
might that alienated by doing that
catholics into the King James Bible
probably not because it was used as sort
of a whipping post against the Catholics
what about Jews they're not gonna be
that happy with with bible reading in in
school what about atheists I think
they're going to be up for that that you
know that was put to the test and we use
the Supreme Court for deciding the sort
of thing and the Supreme Court said no
you can't do bible readings in school
not in any sort of devotional way you
could actually read the King James Bible
you know as an example of British
literature you could teach a Bible as
literature class if you wanted to but
you would not be able to teach it as it
is the official religion or you know
taking a stand and saying this is this
is we're reading this because this is
true you can teach it as this is a
historical document that we can even
look at and out for its own intrinsic
value as a historical document but you
can't actually make it part of your
curriculum school prayer you know falls
under the same sort of thing used to be
that they would actually pray in school
and act out challenge as that was a
matter of establishment book also talks
about one other thing in this chapter
that I skipped over it we should come to
a cute because this is actually kind of
partisan and this is this notion of
civil religion and civil religion is
weird kind of hybrid it's not really the
religion of any particular church or
denomination instead it's sort of like
the religion of the nation think of the
nation considered as a religious
narrative or I think about people who
are particularly important in the
history being elevated to a kind of
sainthood like George Washington was
George Washington was considered to be a
really central character people talked
about him in terms that they would
reserved for people like Moses
what do you think the next really big
president like that would be in America
yesterday moving forward from George
Washington it's not Jefferson's now
Madison's is kind of a I don't wanna say
it's all guy like Athens but he
certainly doesn't inspire that sort of
religious devotion Gazans I like yeah
yeah I really like you yeah why it
wasn't just a beer yeah that makes you
look at a patriarchal but what was it
about this guy that would tie in with
with religious imagery I mean the whole
Civil War by the way shot through
religious imagery Battle Hymn of the
Republic read the words it's about God
you know smiting the slaveholders and
the army of the Lord marching on and
sung to the tune of john brown's body
what was Lincoln known for besides
getting you know in part getting the
Civil War going by getting elected
previous lazy okay he's the great
Emancipator now that has biblical
residences to it what he happens to as
it is a result not just so you know
reenacting the union making a lot of
tough decisions it's kind of like a
martyr exactly and for some people he's
made into like a Christ figure you can
find images of Lincoln like this
particularly from that time these the
one who shed his blood for the nation
that's particularly biblical religious
imagery that's part of American civil
religion ironic in part because Lincoln
didn't go to church he was raised
earlier on the actus but that more or
less leaves all that sort of stuff
behind but he knew how to use
imagery very well you know if you read
the Gettysburg Address for example this
is still part of American politics and
not just on the part of the right you
know I don't know you guys probably
don't remember this because you were a
bit young at the time but the last major
primary election for the Democrats in
two thousand while the whole thing got
started in about two thousand six and
went to two thousand eight the two main
candidates we're Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama I met a whole you know
phenomena of other people as well chill
by all these other all these other
people guess where they started their
election campaigns to churches across
from town we actually didn't religious
studies called the dueling churches
Hillary Clinton started and I forget and
forget one started at a fair remember
anything it was an American methodist
episcopal church and the other one in
the American Methodist Episcopal Zion
Church and if I remember right they both
started in at something on the Alabama
it might have been somewhere else in
Alabama and because they were
commemorating you know civil rights and
each one led a march that began at a
church with a sermon so you've got these
Democratic candidates who are doing you
know using American civil religion
basically as part of the election
campaign this is really stock and trade
this is not something peculiarly a
Republican or Democrat this is something
that pervades American politics and you
know were they there at those churches
because they really cared about that
churches perspective on things no they
wanted something that was kind of
representative of what they what they
stood for that elements of the civil
rights struggle made its way into
american civil religion there's a lot of
elements to this
so that's a theme that's going to come
up over and over again I don't want to
spend too much time now let's look at
that the second grade of week and some
of these things that are happening after
the American Revolution I'm going to
leave this establishment up here because
that plays a central role in what's
going on so if you can't have a official
religion how do you get people to go to
your church you can't rely on the state
to require people who love your trash
well people have to choose right this is
what we call voluntary ISM Walton prison
your book has kind of afraid term for it
not voluntary is amiss with a comment
what does this mean those who belong to
a particular church are there because
they choose to it's a voluntary act of
their own churches are voluntary
associations they're not a government
association there's something that the
people themselves want to participate in
want to belong to another thing that
goes along with this is what your phone
calls denominationalism denomination it
comes from the word to name two
denominates no minute latin means name
and so different groups would be
denominated still kind of tangled
language there is a denominator on the
basis of what it was that tied them
together so if we're talking about
Catholics as a denomination what did
Catholics have in common with each other
you know what makes somebody a Catholic
seven sacraments
frese are married you know what are
those things you'd think of with respect
to Catholics that's part of what goes
into their denomination Presbyterians
this is what makes Presbyterians similar
to each other believe in predestination
having a Presbyterian structure their
denomination Quakers our denomination
Baptist denomination each of them are
distinct as a sort of tradition that's
what we've been studying so far a lot of
what religion of America consistent is
learning about different denominations
and where they came from what their
history is how they intersect with each
other why they believe the things that
they believe why they do the things that
they do we're really studying a lot of
different denominations and we even use
this term not just with Christian
religions when we look at Judaism we
talk about Jewish denominations so what
makes the city Jews different from
Reform Jews you know think about it
acidic Jews what do we know what are the
things you associate with them
particular way of dress em kosher law
they actually follow the kosher law most
Reform Jews kind of you know it's a much
more individualistic thing as a matter
of fact one of the things that I
mentioned when we're talking about
Judaism I think last couple times ago is
the Reform Jews they sort of like said
screw the kosher laws in such a way that
they're their first main gathering edge
for himself shrimp is forbidden by
kosher law so that's that's something
that sets denominations apart I don't
know how well you can apply it to all
different religions but people do I will
talk about Hinduism is somebody a shiva
worshiper ass I fight or the addition
worshiper by sea life so we use this
notion of denominationalism quite a bit
in this is all part of the Second Great
Awakening so the first Great Awakening
you know sort of upsurge in religious
fervor and ideas and practices the
second one takes place after the
American Revolution and it takes place
in a couple phases and in a couple
different places and one of the things
that comes out of this besides
volunteerism and denominationalism let
me disestablishment over here is what we
have come to call the term associated
this is evangelical so you've heard of
evangelical Christians which a lot of
people mix up with other groups like
fundamentalists totally different group
we'll talk about why they drive or
Pentecostals different group
evangelicals as a sort of self-conscious
group fit into the Second Great
Awakening term had been around for a
while as your book mentions this is who
were these evangelicals the word itself
had a long history but evangelical comes
to take on a new meaning in America
partly through this this Great Awakening
there's a designation for anglo-american
Protestants that encompass is not just
one denomination but a whole host of
Protestant denominations
Congregationalist Presbyterians
Methodists and Baptists so let me
actually put those those turkeys down
Congregationalists
wish I had someone you just write this
stuff for me cuz my Spelling's slowing
me down Presbyterians remember to at the
time of the revolution two largest
groups in the United States two largest
religious groups Baptists soon to become
one of the major foot layers and
Methodists also what we call low Church
Episcopalians and if you take these in
your talking about the majority of
religious believers in the colonial
another post-revolutionary the United
States who's not Catholics Jews high
Church Anglicans Quakers remember the
Quakers some of the things that divide
them whether they were becoming
evangelical or not some of the things
that we're seeing now should start to
come together for you as we're reading
through this see what makes them into to
evangelicals your book talks about three
major traits one of these is a limit to
the bible bible is sole source of
religion sole source of religious
authority revelation yeah that's not
that different than other Protestants
though right where I'm Luther sola
scriptura so that's not by itself enough
to make it an evangelical another thing
that we saw come in with the first Great
Awakening was an insistence on personal
emotional conversion
or if we want to speak about it these
terms of heart religion right
evangelical Christianity is about the
relationship of the individual believer
to Christ and it's not just through the
head through the hearts through the
emotions or the religious affections and
it requires some sort of conversion
narrative to to be there and then third
this is where the word evangelical
actually takes us is what they're
calling in the book the mission
imperative go out and spread the gospel
the word evangelical by the way comes
from the word for gospel I mean Greek
it's uh you and gallium the good news
and then Atlantic becomes even jelly um
so in fragile sylvia von scheele the
gospel of st. john would be the evos you
this on Jenna and so this word
evangelical is actually coming from the
roots for four Gospels so when you see
the angelical thing gospel going out and
actually spreading it so that that's
what the mission imperative part means
that it's not enough just to have one's
own personal relationship with God one
has to also go out and offer that to
other people so you'll see evangelicals
saying things like I'd like to tell you
about Jesus you know my personal Lord
and Savior did you have a couple minutes
I'd like to tell you this story about
how I used to be whenever it on drug
addict and he changed me etc you can go
to a lot of different stories like this
right that's part of what it means to be
an evangelical not to keep your
proverbial light under a bushel to hide
it under under a bucket so
evangelicalism is a major part of this
this this Great Awakening and it fits in
very well with these focuses on
volunteerism volunteerism
denominationalism if you don't like the
church that you're in if it doesn't you
know appeal to you because it doesn't
there's nothing really there that's
gripping you emotionally just go to
another Church that's what Walter
volunteerism means you don't have to go
to the state church because there isn't
any state church go to the church that
actually suits your needs the best so if
you find yourself attracted to the
Baptist bleh sounds like the Baptist
Church the Baptist denomination is for
you if you find yourself more drawn to
order structure then maybe the methodist
church is the church for you or the
presbyterian church all these sorts of
things sort of fit in with each other
and your book talks about some of the
geography of this and I'm actually going
to going to skip over quite a bit of
that there is something there there's a
few things that are particularly
important that I want to pick out since
we're getting very short on time one is
your book talks about revivals and so I
should put this as let's call it
revivalism since we've got all these
other isms up there what's a religious
revival it's where you have preachers
that would come in and very often people
would like something set up a tent
village and then there'd be a particular
area where preaching was going on more
or less non-stop and people would come
from from all around and then things
would start happening is your book
mentions during one of these these the
cane the cane Ridge festival all sorts
of things start happening to people
psychomotor things like barking jerking
falling dancing laughing all of these
are things that we might look at and say
wow that person is like having a seizure
but they interpreted that as the Holy
Spirit acting through that
person all these spirits are gripping
this is this by the way it's going to be
leading later on to other things like
that yeah and this is having these
revivals every so often became part of
American prominent ISM at least
evangelical protestantism your book also
mentions this guy Finney and this is
something that perhaps some of you can
either late to my experience or you've
seen this on TV he made some innovations
like the anxious bench that's a seat
place near the revivalist on though on
which those who appeared to be on the
brink of conversion to be placed and
then worked on intensively when they
have altar calls and they say you I can
tell the spirit is working in you come
on down here and then like you stay at
in front of me I start talking
one-on-one dialoguing with you that's
the the equivalent of the anxious bench
that they're talking about here there
you know I have you sit on a bench and
talk to you like that nowadays everyone
stands up protracted meetings meetings
that would go on for a much longer time
are likely to produce these sorts of
conversions so the Second Great
Awakening this here is a great line that
they have revivalists for the shock
troops of this initiative the revivals
help to secure beachheads you guys
understand this military terminology
like when we have D Day and we invaded
France northern France not the Nazis up
you have the beachhead what's your first
take then you have to fortify that and
then you fan out into the countryside so
the revivalists would would sort of
establish the beachhead and then the
churches would come in after them which
churches these churches mostly Baptists
and Methodists some Presbyterians and
they would consolidate those gains the
revivalists might get all these people
converted but then they have to have a
place to go they need some some
structure so like it says the Baptist
and Methodist it really did well with
this
wyd remember how we talked a couple
classes ago about portable religion if
you don't have to have a lot of
apparatus like you don't need a bishop
telling you what to do or you don't need
a you know special church so that you
can do all the rituals it's very easy to
transport that from place to place
remember we're talking about a nation
which is in the process of expanding and
it's always expanding along the frontier
and the frontier is always under
developed until they reach you know
where the French were like in st. Louis
another surprise for them financially
but for the most part they're always
going out to the wilderness and they
have to establish new order new churches
if you can have a church just by getting
people together building a building and
grab a Bible and start talking that's
very easy to move from place to place to
place so this is what we often call a
lone church emphasis another word for
that is evangelical this is where
evangelical Christianity really has its
origins antedated fundamentalist
Christianity or castle Christianity